[Music]
new york city the bagel capital of the
world
the place where bagels reign supreme and
are cut above the rest right
well maybe not because it turns out
there's something that could rock new
york and its precious bagels to the core
[Music]
montreal has their own booming bagel
industry and there's a constituency of
bagel enthusiasts that actually consider
montreal bagels better than new york's
shocking i know i lived in new york for
50 years but i don't care for the new
york bagels and neither does my family
prepare bagel the new york
bagel de maria
what is going on here it's time to
investigate my name is robert morena and
i'm the co-owner of san diego bagel shop
people really know about us and they
know that if you come to montreal you
gotta try montreal bagel
every time i go to new york i always
visit a bagel bakery and i test my
bagels against theirs and i've yet to
come across something that
compares to a singular baby
[Music]
montreal bagel
is set aside by its process of how it's
made
we hand roll each bagel
we boil it in honey water we seed it
and we bake it in a wood-fired oven all
right so montreal's got the sweet and
doughy flavor what do you got to say
about that new york montreal bagels yeah
i think it's mostly a fat honey water
who does that not good i'm speaking that
far sorry my name is darren dolphy and
i'm the operations manager with h
midtown bagels east if you want a
regular bagel you can go anywhere if you
want a true new york city staple you
come to hmh midtown bagels east
look it's new york city we're moving at
a fast pace we sell a lot of bagels some
bagels are made on a machine others are
hand rolled like our cinnamon raisin big
deal still same great taste it's a very
labor intensive process that takes
roughly 24 hours from start to finish
before we can bake off the bagels so you
each have your own process big deal how
do you eat them so generally we do not
cut our bagels and they come out of a
wood fired oven they don't need to be
toasted you come you pick up the bagels
and they buy a tub of cream cheese and
you would make the bagels yourself
that's the real montreal way of doing
things got it so in montreal i have to
make it myself what about new york
when you walk into h midtown bagels east
you walk to the counter place your order
we slice the bagel we put cream cheese
we put the locks we wrap it up and it's
ready to go new york started
manufacturing bagels before montreal the
big difference is that we just kept our
bagel making tradition the same
still horse and wagon so if you're more
of a sweet and doughy do-it-yourself
bagel maker montreal's for you but if
you prefer the toasted bagel with
everything on it you gotta come to new
york but in the end
if there's one thing we can all agree on
it's that everything's better with cream
cheese
[Music]
[Music]
you